quinze jours d'occupation des locaux de
la maternité officiellement fermé depuis
le 19 octobre puis le départ d'une
marche sur paris
les habitants du blanc ne sont pas
résignés à la perte de ce service public
on s'était appelés à beaugency un repas
chaud leur est servi par une habitante
mais ce sont les communes qui depuis dix
jours abrite leur marche de salle des
fêtes en gymnase l'accueil est
formidable
on est accueilli par des communes qui
nous ont aidés salle pour y dormir qui
prépare à manger qui nous font un bel
accueil qui comprenne bien quelles sont
les enjeux de notre marché de notre
combat cette marche ils ont rappelé la
marche des oreilles des oreilles
destinée à ceux qui n'entendent pas ou
ne veulent pas entendre
l'objectif de cette marche c'est d'être
entendu d'où les l'histoire des oreilles
on amène des oreilles au gouvernement
pour qu'il nous entende et on
on accepte l'ensemble des soutiens qu'on
trouve sur le chemin donc des mères qui
nous accueille le président du conseil
régional qui depuis le début nous
soutient n'a pas plus de chance que nous
à obtenir la reprise des négociations
mais on se dit que tous ensemble on va
finir par y arriver
rencontrer le président de la région
centre val de loire les marcheurs sont
devenus cycliste le long de la loire à
vélo
orléans françois bonneau qui comptent
parmi leurs alliés de la première heure
étendent leur porte-voix
il faut écouter la voix des territoires
il faut écouter la voix des femmes et
des hommes qui disent la vérité leur
victime c'est aussi la vérité c'est la
vérité quand on dit que demain on ne
sera pas en sécurité
si vous faire 70 ou 80 kilomètres pour
aller trouver la maternité
aujourd'hui comme hier des décisions
totalement aveugles sont prises
s'agissant de la présence médicale sur
les territoires
les marcheurs du blond croiseront sans
doute des gilet jaune un rond point ou
un autre d'ici leur arrivée à l'elysée
puisque tel est leur objectif proclame
sans ce que vivent les habitants des
territoires éloignés de l'elysée ils
auront sans doute de quoi échanger